[Music]
welcome back a special report from New
York tonight
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan is the top
Republican on the House Oversight
Committee also serves on the Judiciary
Committee he joins us live from Capitol
Hill congressman thanks for being here
I'm gonna start just get your assessment
on this day as transcript and where
things stand tonight well I mean if this
transcript is the reason the Democrats
gonna move forward with impeachment it
just shows you this is not about facts
this is not about the truth this is just
a pretext for them to do what they've
always wanted to do Matt remember
they've been investigating going after
this president since July 31st 2016 and
they're looking for anything that can
hang their hat on because Brett remember
the Michael Cohen hearing was a flop
that John Dean hearing was a flop the
Bob Muller hearing was a flop the Moller
report was a flop the Lewandowski
hearing was a flop so they're trying to
figure out well maybe maybe this
transcript but even they have said there
was no quid pro quo the Democrat
chairman themselves said there was no
quid pro quo here there was no talk
about holding up foreign aid from the
president zalinsky the president of
Ukraine said he wasn't pushed so this is
just the Democrats out to get the guy we
elected president plain and simple all
right here is a compilation of some of
those Democrats today and and you
rightly point out that it depends on
which prism you're looking through how
it was perceived of this transcript that
here the Democrats when you ask someone
to do a favor you owe that person
something in return and when that person
is a foreign leader that means as
president of the United States one day
you will have to put a foreign leaders
interests ahead of America's interests
this is a powder keg coercing a foreign
leader into digging up dirt against a
political rival for the president's
political gain to win re-election even
if there were absolutely no input the
man itself is a betrayal
presidency and a misuse of that office
and any use of the presidency for
private and personal political gain is a
violation of his oath and ought to be
impeachable as an offense your response
there's just one problem with all that
Brett the president of the Ukraine said
today that he wasn't pushed at all on
that phone call he said he wants to
drain the swamp in the Ukraine just like
President Trump is draining the swamp
here so the Democrats can say all they
want Brett here's what we know here's
what we know this whistleblower this
so-called whistleblower didn't have any
first-hand knowledge of what took place
was it on the call
I bet this whistleblower it hasn't even
seen the transcript until today but we
do know this about the whistleblower he
had a political bias against the
president the inspector general told us
that so those are the facts we know the
whistleblower goes to the IG they tell
this committee Inspector General he
looks at this kicks it up to the odni
the director national intelligence the
director national intelligence says
there's nothing there so what's the
inspector general do he goes around the
Director of National Intelligence and
sends a letter to Adam Schiff to create
this crazy ordeal we've witnessed the
last several days and the Democrats can
say all they want but it doesn't square
with the facts and doesn't square with
what the president of the Ukraine said
today here's what they they're saying
congressman and that is that if it was
President Obama you would have a
different tune tonight if it was
President Obama talking to a leader
first about military aid and then saying
can you do me a favor to investigate Don
jr. and his business dealings that you
would have a problem with all of that is
that what's the response to that the
different tune is the Democrats Joe
Biden's son Brett Joe Biden's son gets
paid $50,000 a month for several years
to work for a company in an area of the
industry that he has no experience in
and then when there's a corruption
investigation into the company he works
for guess what his dad who has a pretty
important position in our government at
the time Vice President Biden says
either you fire that guy or we're gonna
hold up aid they're the ones who have
changed their tune not us 50,000 bucks a
month who gets
I mean I got people III get the
privilege of representing who don't make
that in a year this guy gets it for
every month for several years and you
don't think that's strange so they're
the ones who have the difference to not
Republicans so what do you think this
goes there's one report that Democrats
have two hundred and thirteen votes they
need 218 do you think a formal inquiry
turns into impeachment articles look you
have to ask them all I know is this is
this is a fulfillment of what Chuck
Schumer said clear back on January 3rd
2017 he said to president-elect Trump he
said if you mess with the intelligence
community they have six ways from Sunday
a giving back at you they started doing
that clear back in I believe in July of
2016
they've continued to do it I think this
is just one more example of those six
ways I think now maybe it's more than
six ways frankly that they've went after
this president do they have the votes
you'd have to ask Nancy Pelosi it
appears they might but I know this the
American people think this is ridiculous
they think it is completely unwarranted
no justification for it and I think most
Americans are pleased with the with the
job the president has done in leading
our country these past three years what
about the job Rudy Giuliani is doing he
doesn't work for the US government but
he is obviously representing the
president and investigating what do you
think of that it's up to the president
the commander in chief if he wants
someone to represent him in certain
areas and do certain tasks that's up to
him all I know is when you look at this
transcript to think that Nancy Pelosi
did did a press conference for what was
in that call what was in that transcript
and they got all these Democrats now
saying they're gonna impeach the
president based on that you got to be
kidding anyone even when even Jerry
never and Adam Schiff in these Democrat
chairs say there was no quid pro quo in
that transcript even they say that you
know there's nothing there but for these
guys it doesn't matter they are out to
get this guy and I think the American
people see through it
congressman you're sure in your mind
that this is going to backfire on
Democrats I don't know what we'll leave
it up to the people but I know I know
the folks in Ohio that I get the
privilege of representing and all around
our great state they understand the good
job president Trump is doing and they
support him and if the election I think
we're today President Trump would win in
a landslide certainly in our state but I
think across the country
constant Jim Jordan up on Capitol Hill
Carson we appreciate the time you bet
thanks Brad